across the country ordinary Americans
from all walks of life are taking
whatever measures necessary to prepare
I'm preparing my family for the total
Destruction of the power grading the
Yellowstone super volcano a financial
collapse and protect themselves
survival is the goal it's into the
spider hole
from what they perceive is the fast
approaching end of the world as we know
it so I'm gonna use like this
thank you
next we go inside the lives of three
committed Preppers I'd say we did pretty
good there don't you who have devised
extensive plans I'm overwhelmed really
with emotion about the equivalent of
eight sticks of dynamite gone to Great
Lengths
and made huge
seasonal sacrifices to ensure their very
survival
the experts will assess their extreme
preps and decide if they have what it
takes to face Armageddon and to survive
two three shots you're going to be
splitting a half this is
Doomsday Preppers
[Music]
somewhere in Central Texas a retired
engineer known only by the Alias Mr
Wayne tends to his three-acre ranch with
his dog Max and spends hours tinkering
in his Workshop
Mr Wayne keeps his real identity a
secret because he's a prepper working on
a plan that requires the element of
surprise
I'm preparing for China's domination of
the world's economy
in times running out
I really believe that China
has a master plan to control all of the
debt practically worldwide and
especially America's debt they saw that
they could use our own system of
capitalism to destroy us China's out for
themselves the American dollar is going
to be worthless people are going to
panic there's going to be pillaging like
you never saw before we're not going to
see it coming everybody should be scared
out of their wits Mr Wayne fears that
one day soon without warning China will
cash in the 1.1 trillion dollars it owns
in U.S bonds flooding the global economy
and driving the Dollar's value down to
zero so every day he monitors Chinese
government activities all you have to do
is uh is Google just type in collapse of
the American dollar
and every article you come has something
about China until we get rid of Our
obligation to China we're at their Mercy
every day I want to be wrong but I just
I'm not wrong
every spare dollar I have goes into
something as far as prepping to date Mr
Wayne estimates he spent 160 thousand
dollars
my wife stays constantly mad at me
because I I take every spare dime that I
can scrounge to to put it into prepping
where she thinks we should put it for
our retirement Mr Wayne believes that if
China instigates an economic collapse
the dollar will become worthless and
commodities will be the new currency to
prepare for financial catastrophe many
preppers are buying gold not Mr Wayne I
wouldn't give you a can of ravioli for a
fifteen hundred dollar gold piece how
could I know 24 karat gold from 18 karat
gold I wouldn't know the value and
neither would anybody else
the first part of Mr Wayne's survival
plan is stockpiling a resource he
believes everyone will desire in a
post-apocalyptic world I planted a
Vineyard and learned how to make wine
[Music]
it's part of my prepping plant the
bottles of wine that I make and I store
are great barter items in the bad times
that are coming if China destroys
America economically Mr Wayne believes
Chinese currency will rise while the
dollar will become obsolete in a
cashless Society his wine will retain
value and be useful for trade currency
that's gonna go immediately into fact is
straight barter people are going to
still want alcohol as much as they want
food and I'll have that I'll have it to
trade
in the last five years he's created a
Vineyard under three acres of land he
grows seven varieties of grapes and
produces 600 gallons of Wayne's World
wine a year
I have uh black Spanish
uh Villa Blanc
aliancino which is an Italian grape and
I have
a note Grigio or whatever it's called
many Preppers believe that having a
long-term stockpile of goods and keeping
it top secret is critical to survival
Mr Wayne is 100 top secret
hidden five feet below this building he
keeps a 550 bottle bartering inventory
when you get the preppy book 101 the
first thing that they always say about
your storage it should be underground
the foundation of the cellar is a 20 by
8 sea container that was installed over
the course of two months for thirteen
thousand dollars it's a good hiding
place and it's cool the structure
maintains a cool constant temperature
ensuring his bartering wine stays good
until Doomsday
as long as you can keep the temperature
below 70. it's preserved forever
Wayne doesn't just keep wine in his
Cellar he has stockpiled enough food to
feed he and his wife for a year among
his supplies are cans of soup ham and
lots of dog food that isn't just for his
dog Max this is my favorite it's chicken
morsels
and they're they're just really good
canned dog food is not regulated by the
FDA for human consumption but it does
contain protein and around 300
life-sustaining calories a can that's
got soybean it's got chicken it's got
corn
um I don't I can't pronounce that next
word but it's got uh horse meat Max my
dog he turns his nose up at this after
China stings us like they're going to
people are going to be begging for this
stuff and they're going to say
you got any more of that dog food and
I'm gonna say no I think I'm Gonna Keep
it for myself it was pretty damn good
stuff so
if an economic assault from China Causes
Chaos at home Mr Wayne fears there will
be widespread desperation and violence
after the first week it's literally
going to be people out in the streets
riding looting they're thinking that
I didn't get food but I could go take it
away from Mr Wang for that he has over
25 guns which include rifles shotguns
and handguns and Mr Wayne has a plan for
a never-ending supply of ammunition the
idea behind us Preppers is to get as
much guns and ammunition for protection
as we can
if China launches a financial strike
against America Mr Wayne fears social
unrest could unleash panic and lead to a
global bullet shortage when the Chinese
do what they do well instantly there
will be no more ammunition made and
you're not going to find it anywhere so
you can't make your own ammunition nice
pretty bullet your guns are useless
Mr Wayne has recruited his cousin Jesse
a licensed arms dealer to serve as his
ammunitions expert and help him make
enough ammo to defend the ranch
just sit here and do this all day long
until you got a big pile of bullets
now that looks like something off of my
tire it is Jesse is melting salvaged car
parts with recycled bullets after the
casting is complete the last step is to
add gunpowder to the casing
got my gun powder I got my casing and I
take one of these pretty bullets stick
it right up here and then I just push it
all the way down until it clicks and
then back up
wow that's easy I'm gonna that's so good
I'm an autograph I'm gonna put my name
on this
[Music]
with the supplies they have on hand
Jesse could make up to 14 000 rounds of
ammo 100 times with the average gun
owner purchases a year
theoretically one shot per inviter would
be all we need
for now our number one priority is to
defend the parameter
Keep The Intruders out
and keep our family inside safe
whatever it takes
Mr Wayne and Jesse are going to field
test the range and accuracy of their new
bullets
China's not upside down here is it
I don't know
if Intruders come to the ranch the pair
plans to unleash a withering spray of
suppressive fire there we go let's give
this one a try
it's got a pretty good kick to it
let me try try round at it
Jesse Mr Wayne are shooting their
targets from 300 feet away the same
distance from Mr Wayne's house to the
edge of his property all right let's use
Mr Wayne here
well only hard thing about target
practice is walking down to the Target
I'd say we did pretty good there don't
you yep no doubt about it Mr Wayne is
satisfied with the range of his Field of
Fire but his defense plan extends Beyond
bullets
all right
Texas prepper Mr Wayne will stop at
nothing to defend his Ranch if China
launches an economic assault he has
developed a two-pronged defense plan
that starts with bullets and ends with a
bang
kids don't do this at home leave this to
the professionals only
very dangerous very very explosive about
the equivalent of eight sticks of
dynamite the second part of Mr Wayne's
defense plan involves the Strategic
placement of explosives he's practicing
building a pipe bomb building real pipe
bombs is a federal offense under U.S law
but after a Chinese economic takeover Mr
Wayne believes weapons restrictions will
be a thing of the past when times go bad
there's not going to be anybody
enforcing anything now I know this is
going to work
I won't say I've tested it before
because they're illegal the best thing I
got to do is figure out where to put
these
we're putting together a little scene
here of the best way to protect your
property Mr Wayne knows the key to a
sound tactical plan is understanding the
Topography of the battlefield so he has
recreated his property's features on a
sand table a tool used by Military
Officers to plot wartime strategy keep
in mind I'm trying to protect my loved
ones I'm going to be up here in the
house this is me the handsome one and
this is Jesse and
these are the kids over here is the bad
guy this is the guy we don't want on the
property and the hardest thing to do is
to know exactly where these intruders
are going to come in from this bird's
eye view he and Jesse can best assess
where to plant phase two of their plan
the most Locker that are going to come
in through that deeper vein and that'll
get them cover to right here in that old
coyote he always run run up through
there to steal the chickens the moment
an intruder is cited Mr Wayne and cousin
Jesse plan to lay down suppressor fire
the initial hail of gunfire will drive
an enemy to the only cover available
we're ready for whoever's gonna come
here but on Mr Wayne's Ranch there is no
safe cover the boulders are rigged to
explode with homemade pipe bombs in
military terms the attacker has entered
the Kill Zone
and all right
ready
that's uh
pretty successful but I think we kind of
blew the perimeter up a little too there
we better hope not too many of these
guys come around are we going to blow
the property up Mr Wayne and cousin
Jesse have determined the best locations
for their explosive rigged Kill Zone now
they will go out into the fields to test
a bomb's blast radius onto this for me
while I get this yeah
you don't want to go too deep because
you want the shrapnel to tear him up too
in this simulation Mr Wayne is lighting
a fuse but if doomsday comes he plans to
detonate the bombs remotely I suggest
that we all run
I'm gonna get right here before it goes
off
come on it's
it went off didn't it all right well
let's go pick up the pieces I guess that
looks like he lost both of us legs yeah
I don't think he's going anywhere nope
tape a couple of legs on him I think
he'll be all right A lot of people like
me are paying attention you can never
stop prepping and you can never be ready
enough for what I see is coming
Mr Wayne the experts Practical Preppers
think you possess many valuable
resources that will enable you to barter
effectively during a crisis situation
well thank you very much while your
underground container will keep your
supplies hidden you will inevitably run
out of food we recommend you start a
garden
a garden is definitely on our plan and I
have the seeds stored
because your series is so popular with
my wife she's come around my way of
thinking and she now supports what I did
while there is some concern about the
Staggering amount of U.S debt owned by
China more than a trillion dollars
analysts believe they are unlikely to
dump that debt because it would also
cause major damage to the Chinese
economy that is in part because the U.S
is one of the largest importers of
chinese-made goods
100 miles away John and Christine
sellers also fear the world as we know
it is going to end
so they are burying something in the
backyard they hope will ensure their
survival and their love
[Music]
where you ride baby I'm ready
[Applause]
[Music]
John and Christine sellers live in a
Four Acre Homestead in rural
Pennsylvania
are the silent majority we're just like
everybody else we get up we go to work
we pay our taxes work for everything we
have and we will defend it all right
honey bunny you ready to give it a try
most weeks the sellers take their
Harleys and a ride through the forested
hills that surround their home
[Music]
but today's ride will be their last
One Last Ride Baby Let's Take One Last
Ride come on get rid of these things
as much as we love the bikes this isn't
a necessity come on baby hop on and now
it's a start to more serious stuff
prepping prepping prepping
John and Christine are selling their
bikes and foregoing any luxuries
all so that they can survive the end of
the world
you're going to do some serious damage
with this
well John and I are preparing for the
collapse of the dollar we think we're
immune here in America we're not immune
it's all going to come down like a deck
of cards one thing I'm not gonna miss
are the bugs good eating baby
we might be eating bugs soon I hope
people start to wake up
they need to wake up it's happening
right in front of their faces I mean
hunter gatherers like the old days just
often think about this we bought a truck
in 2001. we were paying 80 cents a
gallon we bought that truck now it's
what over three dollars four times as
much in 10 years but I didn't get a a
400 race I'll tell you that I know it's
going to get bad so I can't eat my bike
Christine fears that if a dollar
collapses the cost of basic necessities
will soar becoming Out Of Reach for the
majority of Americans people all know
when the dollar collapses when you go to
the store and you can't afford to feed
your family on what you make for a week
so in Readiness Christine has spent the
last year and a half and nearly thirty
thousand dollars stocking up on fifteen
thousand pounds of Supermarket supplies
it's one little Supermarket like a
bodega or a little 7-Eleven down here
this bottle of peanuts last year I gonna
sell for 1.79 I think they're like
almost six dollars now so I probably
have well over 400 rolls of toilet paper
I figure that should be enough for a
minimum of two years probably have about
150 toothbrushes I have a minimum of 2
000 napkins minimum I was losing my mind
with how much she was spending on things
I was hiding stuff underneath the bed
because I just didn't want to hear his
mouth and I would always say to him what
good is the money going to be in the
bank if we're not going to be able to
Ink yeah I got your cup right here why
are you having a fresh one all right I
just got on board with her not too long
ago I know a lot of business owners I
see what they're going through
it's getting worse and worse and worse
in March 2011 the cost of living for the
average American hit a record high and
experts predict a continuing rise in
food prices
ah it's a good cup of coffee aren't you
glad I have instant coffee in my
prepping now that John's on board boy
boy we're forced to be reckoned with
because with him in my corner I can't
lose
and together they are ready to use their
combined Force to protect their stores
from those who did not prep for an
economic collapse
we have a TV over there so if he's if
I'm sitting over here and John's over
there and we hear somebody coming up the
stairs what's the temple is opening up a
drawer and there's your protection 357
Magnum we just keep it here for fun the
nine millimeter we have Old Faithful the
Mossberg 500 there's going to be a lot
of people in a bad way when it's a fan I
mean they're going to be breaking in
your house trying to get a bottle of
water this one is a Taurus 44 magnum
this is a big badass and when did I get
you that I got a Christmas present from
mama here our home is our Castle Johnson
mine I'm not gonna depend on the place
defend me I'm gonna spend on my 308 my
357 my 45 Colt my AK my AR my mossenburg
shotgun that's it end of story 2-3 shots
you're going to be splitting half and
your people that are with you they're
gonna run the other way they're gonna
say this woman is crazy with most of
their savings invested into their
extensive preps John and Christine want
to do all they can to protect them so
they're looking for a way to ensure what
they have we have thousands and
thousands of dollars invested in food
now we have to find a way to safely
secure it all right and these Preppers
Hope Insurance will come in the form of
an underground bunker an economic
collapse we're not going to have
utilities we might not be able to get
fuel we have to preserve our food we
have to keep it in a constant
temperature but it'll be really nice
right over here I'd say this way it's
not close to the house the sellers
believe a buried bunker will give them
several advantages it can act as a root
seller keeping their food stores cool
and preventing spoilage and they can
store their preps off-premises
safeguarding them from Plunder 55
degrees all year right underground after
you get down below the frost lines we
can get some natural sunlight and if
necessary the bunker can also act as a
temporary home to fall back to in case
their house is invaded if somebody comes
in and overwhelms us and we're on our
property at least we have a like a panic
room but it's going to be underground
maybe get a little propane we have the
propane stove we're gonna be able to
live in there if we have to right
exactly
[Music]
wow gives us a lot of space but until
the couple can save more money they will
have to wait until spring break to break
ground we're gonna get it but then what
you're gonna have to do is carb you're
spending
being agreement on that yeah okay John
and Christine fear any money they earn
will drop in value before they can use
it to buy a bunker so they take all
extra cash and use it to buy alternative
currency which they believe will not
significantly depreciate the dollar is
going to collapse it's not a matter of
if it's a matter of when the new
currency John and I formally believe
it's going to be gold silver guns and
ammo hello yo what's going on how are
you what's happening several times a
month Christine and John head to the
local pawn shop to buy up what they can
today they are in the market for some
silver
this is the stuff that I save for you
guys okay
so sure those are good coins and some of
them are in very good dates and a very
good condition I'm not saving money in
the savings account anymore what's the
point it's going to be worthless silver
bars and American junk coins this is
more sounds than paper money the average
savings account today gives a yearly
return of under one percent while the
value of silver has nearly tripled since
2008 rising from just eleven dollars to
over 32 dollars an ounce We Believe
Silver's really hasn't hit its High Mark
I believe Silver's going to go to 500 an
hour I think so too yeah Portugal will
be 99.25 and the gold per your pick up
later yes okay he'll come pick it up I'm
definitely going to their house on
doomsday because my house is not going
to cut I am welcome to you're welcome
he's coming with us don't lose it my
friend
once at home Christine and John deposit
the pawn shop silver into their own
version of a Preppers Bank
John is making a small waterproof
container of PVC piping for the 2500
worth of silver
it's a couple on tape to seal it
and that makes the water silk
let's go seal right up
what we're doing is sort of like a time
capsule and what this is we're going to
bury it
[Music]
I think we should bury it on the
southern side of the garage this way we
have the garage as a buffer the reason
why we're choosing behind the a house
behind the garage to bury this is if our
house is commandeered no one's going to
see us coming from the rear end of our
property so at least we can retrieve our
silver we're still going to survive
Christine estimates they have buried
over thirty thousand dollars worth of
silver in small stashes around their
property
we have a little map that map is secure
someplace off the premises you don't
want to start digging holes all over the
place you want to be pretty precise a
good idea if you're going to bury things
on your own property you want to put it
anywhere near your house and to use the
PVC tubing because this is waterproof
John and Christine have put their life
savings into prepping sacrificing in the
present to survive in the future but
without Christine's knowledge John has
decided that it is time to break the
rules forty four hundred dollars
wow I'm overwhelmed really with emotion
and John Sellers are beginner Preppers
afraid that the collapse of the dollar
is just around the corner prepping
really did bring us together honestly
now we think alike and we know what
we're prepared for and where we're
headed so we have to stay together on
this recently they have been looking at
ways to up their prepping game and have
started to save money to buy an
underground bunker since John and I
became Preppers my priorities have
changed I don't buy clothes I don't buy
purse shoes I don't really care about
that kind of stuff I told my husband do
not buy me jewelry do not send me
flowers but despite plans to wait until
the spring John has decided to jump the
gun and surprise Christine with her
dream shelter
so today while she is at work he's going
on a shopping spree they go at about
forty four hundred dollars I'll go look
at them yeah that's seriously
all right we'll go check them out you
can just follow me all right bunkers
have traditionally been an expensive
Affair costing upwards of one hundred
thousand dollars recently a new product
has come on the market that preppers are
snapping up as quickly as they can
yeah these things are sweet Donuts
shipping containers are used to
transport Goods across the ocean they
can cost up to five thousand dollars
each making them more affordable than a
concrete bunker
storage container is all about
protecting what you have we work hard
for everything we have and we don't want
to lose it all the way all right guys
it's okay sweet yeah first thing I'm
gonna have to do is put some shelves in
here there's definitely a big demand for
these this is a Third customer that
we've had that's told me that they're
going to build an underground bunker
yeah these are nice man
the storage container is a perfect place
to put some food maybe a few guns that
you can hide in there and you might have
to sleep in that storage container it's
big enough to do it
because they are built to cross the
ocean shipping containers are durable
and watertight making them attractive
building materials for Preppers
[Music]
yeah this is going to be a surprise I
want this uh at the house before the
wife comes home thanks man filling me
around man appreciate it man with the
deal done John organizes same-day
delivery scheduled to arrive just an
hour before Christine gets home
sweet
oh my goodness gracious
ah I bought it honey I bought it ah
honey that's your present honey for
Christmas
foreign
did you get your stuff in there
I'm just like
I'm just I'm in shock we're professional
Preppers with this we went from the
novice maybe to the semi-pros this is
beautiful this is better than a five
carat diamond ring to me or the Tiffany
Stone because this is survival survival
baby this is the best
you could have ever done really honest
we need it right we need it it's
practical I'm overwhelmed really with
emotion really
[Music]
house
love you love you are you ready yeah
wow
nice huh wow
the experts Practical Preppers commend
you on the amount of preps you have been
able to build up in just a year and a
half and your decision to buy a shipping
container is a smart investment for the
future
I like that
however despite your extensive food
preps you must face the reality that
they will eventually dwindle you need a
resupply plant in the form of gardening
or hunting to see you through a
long-term crisis
I have hunting skills and I can hunt and
do hunt and also uh we have seeds and
we're going to prepare a garden as
Preppers we know that that's one skill
we do lack
a lot more
to make a large Garden and we're going
to can a lot of the vegetables that's
what our plans are we hope all the rest
of America does the same thing
do the best you can to get through the
hard times that are coming
Jason day is a Furniture repairman who
runs a shop on Main Street in Miamisburg
Ohio
it's always a new piece of artwork to me
every piece I lay my fingertips on my
mother says from God's eyes to my
fingertips Jason's lived his whole life
in this part of Central Ohio
he met his wife here
and had his kids here each one born on a
holiday she was born on Flag Day he was
born on Valentine's Day and he was born
on New Year's Day
their last name today lately there's one
other day that's become a big part of
family life my dad builds furniture and
he prepares for 2012 which is doomsday
if being prepared is crazy that I'm a
crazy man because I'm definitely one of
the most prepared people in the world
because we prep we've lost cars we've
lost houses we've taken a real big loss
at home for the past six years Jason has
spent every dollar he's earned from his
furniture shop nearly one hundred
thousand dollars total on prepping for
doomsday
my wife first got together we traveled a
lot went to Disney World Florida
actually enjoyed ourselves and now
instead of going to Disney World we'd
rather buy a case of dehydrated food or
buy a case of water or a couple gas
masks chemical suit whatever needs to be
to get the job done Jason's wife Tanya
Works full-time in a medical lab to
cover all the household bills
right now because the world's not coming
in it's kind of bad because I would like
to go on vacation and my kids would too
but if the president of the United
States came on the air and said okay I
need you guys to evacuate now or you're
going to die I know that me and my kids
would be just fine
devoting half the family's income to
prepping is a matter of personal
responsibility for Jason
from his storefront on Main Street he
believes he's already seeing signs that
dark days are coming
okay
my doomsday scenario is the economy
collapsing
for my
one two three four five six no you
skipped this one there's thousands and
thousands of people out there without
jobs Dayton Ohio is nothing but a
manufacturing City we're not
manufacturing nothing I'm about to give
you a good lesson you know what happens
when you work real hard your entire life
you get a lot of money someone reaches
over and takes it all brand new
facilities to make vehicles or be shut
down and all those people don't have
jobs people are going to be starving I
think we're already on a spiral downhill
counting on other countries for our
resources and our food that could bring
death and doom to you know many people
in the United States
Jason is determined to get his whole
family through an economic apocalypse
but as his prepping intensifies are they
up for the challenge gas mask drills
and I know he's prepared
Furniture repairman Jason dang believes
America faces a financial collapse that
will end Life as we know it and he's not
alone 51 of Americans believe we might
face a catastrophic economic meltdown in
the next 25 years every great nation has
always come to an end America is just
the same way do you say you know the
metal detectors are working
yeah they should be the dollar does drop
one way to buy food or to buy gear or to
even just to make it day for day will be
trading gold and silver and precious
metals right now I have a thousand to
two thousand dollars with the gold and
silver I think we should take the metal
detectors out there and see if we can
find anything
[Music]
Jason uses weekends to train his kids to
find more goals for the family's
Doomsday coffers
all the vacations that we have to give
up
it's only a ride that we can do some
things fun on the weekend
make sure you get the seat belt on about
three years ago because we have family
vacation where we had fun we did the
Indiana Zoo but it ended up being to
where we were prepping to where we went
and we looked for rocks and gold you
guys ready to go paying for some gold
yeah
it's fun
at least we got to go to the zoo
gold isn't abundant in Ohio but Jason
hopes his family can find enough to help
Finance their Preps
foreign
yep there's something right here check
it out
I found a quarter
[Music]
a bit
let's take it down in here get some
fresh water toss it around a little bit
and let it go over those cracks the
reason we let it run out of those cracks
is because gold weighs more than other
minerals so the gold will get stuck in
the cracks if we have gold and if the
economy was to break I would have some
type of bargaining chip something to
trade for food and something to use for
bartering just a gold dust right there
there's two specks of gold right there
one there and one there that's real gold
after hours of prospecting the days are
headed back to town to assess their find
my kids and I have been out prospecting
here in Centerville and we think we
found a few flakes of gold and we were
just curious on if there was any value
to it
pawn shops like this one have become
popular destinations for Preppers
worried about financial collapse many
accept precious metals in lieu of cash
or even exchange gold and silver for
firearms if you wanted to sell that we'd
go about six dollars so what do you
think hold on to it save it save it save
it
yeah I agree with you hopefully the
value of it'll Skyrocket uh from six
dollars to something panning for gold is
really fun but if I had to keep doing
that every day and I could only make six
dollars that's just not gonna be a
Lifeboat Jason estimates he spends 15
hours a day seven days a week on
prepping activities like looking for
goals buying supplies or even just
window shopping online for his dream
prep a bunker for the whole family
here's another one that I found so how
much is that 75 000. isn't that a price
of a house yeah but with the economy
going down the way it is the house isn't
going to save us Tanya supports his
passion but it has meant some
adjustments his time preppy he's not at
home as much
so I think I miss him more and I think
the kids do too yeah see you there
say good girl
it's just I love him
and I know what he's prepared
I just really do know if anything were
to happen we'd be fine
really
that's why
he does what he does
really
Jason would do anything to keep the
people he loves safe I don't want to see
my kids go through hell if America faces
a catastrophic economic collapse his
first action will be to bring his family
to his store where he has enough
supplies to sustain them for the first
two to six months of expected chaos a
lot of the Doomsday preps I do have I
don't necessarily want to keep it at
home in their face all the time I want
them to have a happy childhood
gas mask drills every one of my kids is
suited and fitted for a gas mask Jason
has invested over two thousand dollars
in gas masks including m25s developed by
the military to protect tank drivers
from chemical attacks so we do go into
an economic collapse with police going
against all the people riding and
gasping thrown that you might have to
use something like that to protect
yourself hey you guys know the drill on
your mark get set go
if chemical weapons were deployed on
Main Street effects could be felt within
30 seconds
where is
Luke
there you go and stop
23.7 seconds good job
going through the gas mask drills with
daddy is this a good time and having fun
hanging out with me you're good you're
good
like a straw in there
walking up it was just not pleasant but
I know that one day I'm gonna have to
put them on and it's good that I know
how to put them on you're good let's go
there's riots this is the difference
between life and death all you check
yours give me five you did it buddy I
never expected that a five-year-old
would be able to take a gas mask
disassemble it put it back together put
filters on it and wear it and my little
boy can do that
the days we'll practice this drill
multiple times this afternoon until
Jason is sure that everyone has it right
Jay Tyler put your mask on get rid of
the chess game I'm throwing the garbage
come on Bobby
Jason has his whole family training for
doomsday but when it comes time to bug
out you don't want to go down you sure
they might not all be on board
I don't think it might be coming with us
Furniture repairman Jason day believes
that the American economy is headed for
disaster
he fears a catastrophic Financial
collapse will start in 2012 and end Life
as We Know It
many Preppers spend hours researching
Bug Out locations near and far Jason has
one option eight miles from home his
furniture shop on Main Street
let's go over here and take a look at
some of this stuff make sure we got
everything we need see if there's
anything we need to add to it
customers don't know that Jason has
turned his store into a fully equipped
prepping complex five thousand dollars
worth of preps are hidden here and the
back room can serve as a makeshift field
hospital if chaos leads to casualties
medical supplies is very important
because when you are on a bug out
situation if people don't have shelter
they're going to try to get in your
shelter
if you're trying to defend yourself
you're definitely going to have people
who are going to get injured this is a
tourniquet it's set up so that if your
arm gets blown off you can use it
one-handed tighten it here to stop the
blood flow radiation pills is very
important these patches right here you
use this here in case that someone gets
shot in the trash whether you know when
economy collapses and we can't count on
hospitals and things like that if my
kids don't know how to survive they're
going to drag us down
they have these IVs so someone's dying
of lack of blood you can go ahead and
hook them up with this and help save
their life
sure baby you can go first
IV or intravenous fluid therapy is often
used to stabilize trauma victims on the
battlefield Jason wants the whole family
to feel comfortable inserting one do you
know what a van feels like it's bouncy
and it's spongy fill it right there all
right hold on no I want you to feel it
first feel that ready
it's all right I just wanted to show you
that I could do it yes if I could put an
IV in here are you saving my life or
trying to kill me
Preppers usually prefer isolated Bug Out
locations away from people but Jason
store on Main Street is highly visible
he hopes he can turn this liability into
an advantage if desperate people try to
flee the city after an economic collapse
Jason and his family can head for its
Center and hide in plain sight
Shop's basement
here's the fan I want to be underground
because it's more secure people can't
see you and if they don't know you're
there your chances of surviving just
went up 100 Going Underground is Jason's
Ultimate Survival plan his family can
effectively disappear here safe from
becoming targets for the unprepared and
with easy access to all the town's
infrastructure
we sure are buddy
[Music]
but before Jason can rely on bugging out
under his shop he wants to make sure his
family is mentally prepared my kids say
that they're ready to live underground
if need be but I don't think anybody can
answer that question really until it's
time people lose their mind as being
underground we like to have weekend
trials where we'll go underground hang
out with each other and find out who's
going to flip out and who's not you
don't want to go down you sure all right
then I love you you go first be careful
one benefit Jason sees to his basement
turned bunker is its single entry point
if someone attacks you and they only
have one door to get through it'd be a
lot easier to protect your building than
if they could come through a wall or go
through a roof what happens if there's
spiders and mice but they only nibble
for a little bit and you'll be all right
here I'll go ahead and set the tarp up
[Applause]
what's the first thing we needed to be
able to cook these uh dehydrated food
chicken teriyaki with rice or scrambled
eggs with bacon
part of acclimating to life underground
is adjusting to a post doomsday diet so
what we would do is we would boil this
water I went ahead and I heated it up
for us before we got down here Jason is
serving his kids freeze-dried food a
prepper staple because it's compact
lightweight and keeps for years
I'm gonna go ahead and close this up and
let the hot water in the steam do its
job he believes they may be eating it
for up to six months after an economic
collapse when we do live underground do
you think mommy JT are ever going to
come down here well yeah sure I do I
think JT will definitely be with us your
mom I hope not
how about Grandma and Grandpa no grandma
and grandpa
um majority of the older people in the
world will not be coming with there's
not anything I wouldn't do to try to
save my family or you know to make sure
that they were going to eat
how's it taste
it's actually pretty good try it
all right here's the thing you guys okay
if something happens to us and we really
have to go underground Jay Tyler and
your mom may not want to go but when
they see that it's the only choice that
they have and their families going with
they'll probably be with us
it's easy for somebody to say right now
that they don't believe or they don't be
a survivalist but when it is the fan
they'll be there I think we should clean
up and get out of here
I actually have a better idea I say we
pull out the sleeping bags and stay down
here tonight are you serious yeah I'm
serious let's give it a shot
[Applause]
listen I know that this isn't gonna be
no piece of cake but by the time
doomsday rolls around you guys be pros
at it and we'll be all right I'm gonna
go shut the door I'll be right back
people ask me all the time what if
you're wasting your time let me ask you
what if I'm not wasting my time and what
if you're about to starve to death or
your kids are about to starve to death
I've got family members who get mad at
me and come up to me like hey Jay you
gonna take us in the bunker with you
let's think about that if I prepared my
entire life if I start pulling people in
there with me who have never prepared a
day in their life I'm just going to kill
the people are prepared for
Jason the experts Practical Preppers
believe you have the basics of survival
covered with your food and medical
supplies
however getting your whole family on
board with a bug out plan is highly
recommended leaving a family member
behind could make an emergency situation
more stressful for your children my wife
says she doesn't want to go underground
and we tease about it all the time but
with kids the fans she'll be there
while hyperinflation and severe economic
depressions have occurred destroying
entire nations monetary systems
economists generally agree that the
United States has sufficient fail-safes
in place to avert such a disaster
foreign
[Music]